you did write a paper towards a grant
unified theory mathematics and physics
um maybe you could step there first what
is the key idea in that paper well i
think we've kind of gone over that i
think that the key idea is what we were
talking about earlier that um
that just kind of a claim that if you
look and see what's that have been
successful ideas in unification in
physics and over the last
um 50 years or so and what
has been happening in mathematics and
the kind of thing that
frankl's book is about that these are
very much the same kind of mathematics
and so it's kind of an argument that
there really
is
you shouldn't be looking to unify just
math or just
fundamental physics but taking
inspiration for looking for new ideas in
fundamental physics that they are going
to be in the same direction of
getting deeper into mathematics and
looking for more inspiration mathematics
from
these successful ideas about fundamental
physics
could you put words to sort of the
disciplines we're trying to unify so you
said number theory are we literally
talking about all the major fields of
mathematics so it's like the number
theory geometry
uh so the differential geometry topology
like yeah so the i mean one one name for
this
that this is acquired in in mathematics
is the so-called language program
and uh so this started out in
mathematics it's that
you know robert langland's kind of
realized that a lot of what people were
doing and um
that was starting to be really
successful in number theory in the
60s and so that this actually
was
anyway that this could be could be
thought of in terms of um
these ideas about symmetry in groups and
representations
and and
in a way that was also close to some
ideas about about geometry
and um then more later on in the 80s and
90s there was something called um
geometric language that people realized
that you could take what people have
been doing in number theory in language
and and and get ri just forget about the
number theory and ask what is this
telling you about geometry and you get a
whole some new insights into certain
kinds of geometry that way
so it's anyway that that's kind of the
name for this area is langlins and
geometric language
and just recently in the last few months
there's been um
there's kind of a really major paper
that uh appeared by uh peter schultz and
laurel farg where they
you know made you know some serious
advance and trying to understand
a very much
kind of a local problem of what happens
in number theory near a certain prime
number and they
turn this into a problem of exactly the
the kind the geometric
language people had been doing these
kind of pure a pure geometry problem and
they
found
by generalizing the mathematics they
could actually reformulate it in that
way and it worked perfectly well
one of the things that makes me sad
is you know i'm a
pretty
knowledgeable person and then
uh what is it at least i'm in the
neighborhood
like theoretical computer science right
and it's still way out of my reach and
so many people talk about like langlands
for example is one of the most brilliant
people in mathematics and just really
admires work
and i can't
it's like almost i can't hear the music
that he composed and it makes me sad
yeah well i mean i i think that
unfortunately it's not just you as i
think even most mathematicians
have no really don't actually understand
this about them in the the group of
people who really understand
all these ideas and so for instance this
paper of
schultz and farg that i was talking
about the number of people who really
actually understand how that works is
anyway one
very very small and so it's uh so i i
think even
you find if you talk to mathematicians
and physicists even they will often feel
that you know there's this really
interesting sounding stuff going on and
which i should be able to understand
it's kind of in my own field i have a
phd in but it still seems it's pretty
clearly far beyond me right now
you